I'm Terry Gerard. I'm Scoutmaster with Group 44 in Collinsville, Oklahoma.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
I heard a cheer go up from one of our patrol campsites on our camp out last weekend
and I was curious to know what all the excitement was about.
so I walked over and I asked and the patrol leader told me
that they had finished a jigsaw puzzle that they brought along in just two hours.
And I said: wow, that's really something good for you.
And the patrol leader said yeah, the box said four to six years.
This is podcast number 213.. Hey,
Whoa,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
John wrote in to say you've been a huge help to me as I get back into the thick of things in scouting.
You provide a great outside opinion on what I see and don't understand in my troop.
Well, John, I'm glad to be of help. Tom wrote in and said: great show this past week.
I enjoyed podcast 212.. I got a lot out of that episode.
There were great specifics and I really like your advice on dealing with new scout parents and leaders.
Setting the right tone and expectations from the get-go is best
A Scoutmaster- or an advisor in my case- needs to be a mentor to youth
and a leader to other scout leaders and parents.
It can be hard to switch gears, but keeping focused on the goal at hand helps.
Keep up the good work. See you around the campfire. Thanks, Tom,
I'm glad you got something out of that.
Andy McDonald did too. He's with Scout Troop 196 in Winnersprings, Florida.
Thank you, as always, for a great podcast.
As the new Scoutmaster, I've been making changes to our troop in the past four months
and this podcast reinforced a number of those that I have implemented.
One of them was that I don't allow adults to make announcements
or to address the troop during meetings unless it's a special occasion like a court of honor.
I ask that they bring announcements to me and I hand them to the senior patrol leader.
Another change is having only registered and trained leaders on camp out.
I've had a little bit of backlash on some of the things.
However, most of the changes have been well received by those that understand
how a troop's supposed to be run.
This podcast gave me another booster shot to keep me going on the same track I've been thus far.
Thank you immensely for everything you do for us.
Thank you, Andy, for getting in touch,
And I'm really happy to hear that you're finding things helpful.
Listen. if you are a regular reader or listener and, like Andy and Tom and John,
you're finding what's offered by ScoutmasterCGcom has helped you,
You can return the favor by becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
Funds from backers go towards the expenses of producing and publishing the blog
and the posts and the podcast,
And they keep these resources freely accessible to Scouters all over the world.
And this past week I want to thank Terry Gerard and John Strohmeier
who stepped up and helped out.
Thank you so much, guys.
I really do appreciate it.
Well, in this week's podcast in ScoutmasterCG, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk about the tremendous, powerful potential of our attitude
when we're dealing with Scouts in that developmental stage of life
that we all know so very well, right?
And then we've got an email question to answer,
So that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
Let's get started, shall we?
Well, I know this probably doesn't happen to you,
but sometimes my Scouts act badly,
I mean just objectively poorly.
Sometimes they're stubborn,
They're lazy,
They're indifferent,
They're short-sighted
And they do foolish things.
Now, why is that happening
And what am I supposed to do about it as a Scouter.
Wouldn't it be great if I could spend the next few minutes
and tell you exactly how to fix all that?
I'm not going to be able to,
But I'm going to be able to share with you some thoughts
about how to work with Scouts in a way that's going to make you
happier and make them happier.
And well, how do I do that
Scouts in a way that's going to make you happier
and make them happier and will help you better achieve
the aims of Scouting.
So why do Scouts act that way?
Why are they that way sometimes?
Well, there's a two-part answer.
One is is that they're human beings
and we're all prone to doing that every once in a while,
no matter what our age,
And the other one is because they're progressing
through a developmental stage of life
that isn't always pretty,
But it's rather predictable and it's very normal and healthy.
I think one of the more useful things I could share with you
is the idea that, to make real progress
and to be useful to our Scouts,
I think there's one key shift in our thinking as adults
that's going to help us do that,
And that is that outside influences are not causing
these problems.
Now, are there objectively bad influences
in the world out there,
Of course,
But are these bad influences
a significant cause of the difficult behavior
and attitudes we see in our Scouts?
I really don't think so,
And let me explain why.
I think it's all too easy for us to blame
these what I would call adolescent instabilities
and uncertainties on outside influences
like- oh I don't know- too much government
or not enough government or society at large,
or general moral decay and shifts in culture.
There's just one fundamental problem
with looking at the world that way:
If we look at the last century
and we look at all of the moral panics
that we're supposed to end civilization as we know it,
All you have to do is go back and look at old newspapers.
I mean votes for women.
We're going to end the world dancing in public.
We're going to end the world with newspapers.
They were horrible. novels-
Oh my gosh. movies,
Oh no. radio.
Radio coming into the home,
Television, the internet, comic books, rock music-
You could just the list is endless. isn't it
A pervasive and broadly accepted formula
that we've all used? is that the things
that we see in our Scouts-
the whole list, stubbornness
and shortsightedness and foolishness-
is caused by some fundamental change in the world
since you and I were kids.
Now our parents and their parents,
and the parents of their parents
all the way back- they in some respects
thought that the world was headed to hell
in a handbasket.
But it didn't turn out to be true, did it?
If we think that way,
most of us end up at one or the other polar extreme.
We can conclude that we're not going to be able
to do anything about this
and we're just going to acquiesce to them,
And this kind of boys-will-be-boys attitude
is dangerous and wrong-headed
and because bad behavior is nothing to ignore,
So I'm not suggesting that we're going to ignore these things, okay.
On the other extreme, we can spend way too much time
and emotional capital fighting these outside influences.
If we focus a lot of aggression- and that's what it becomes-
on fighting outside influences,
that aggressiveness spills over into the way
that we work with our scouts and we start doing things
that send very clear messages to them that
you know we really don't like them very much
And we kind of draw a line between ourselves and them
And what we end up with is not what we want to have,
which is a partnership together with them in development.
We end up with an us and them kind of mentality.
I mean, if you start a direct attack on stubbornness
and laziness and indifference and short-sightedness
and foolishness, you're taking on society
and you're going to lose.
You're just going to lose in the end.
BF Skinner in Walden II- if you've ever read the book,
said this: each of us has interests
which conflict with the interests of everybody else.
Everybody else we call society
It's a powerful opponent and it always wins.
Society wins in the long run
because it has the advantage of numbers and age.
So if we're not going to fight society,
if we're not going to take a head-on assault
on all these difficult things that we see in scouts,
what are we supposed to do?
Well, what we're supposed to do is apply scouting,
and everything in scouting has a positive message behind it.
On my honor, I will do my best to do my duty to God
in my country and to obey the scout law,
to help other people at all times,
to keep myself physically strong, mentally awake
and morally straight. There's not a negative in there.
A scout is trustworthy, loyal, helpful, friendly, courteous,
kind, obedient, cheerful, thrifty, brave, clean and reverent.
There's no do-nots in there.
There's no prohibitions and there's no definitions.
The scout oath and law, we're making a promise to ourselves.
We're making an affirmative declaration
of the kind of person that we want to be
and we're aspiring to become that kind of person.
We aren't saying we're going to battle anything,
but that we are going to be something.
And with that promise and that law at its basis,
scouting becomes this marvelous, positive journey
about finding out what these things mean.
If we focus all that we do as scouters on those positive things-
and we all have them committed to memory,
so it should be pretty easy to do-
we don't have to battle with negative things-
And you've heard this before. right,
Instead of cursing the darkness, you turn on a light.
and it's an old, tired phrase, but it's true.
If we aim consciously and intentionally
at building an internal standard of what good is in our scouts,
we don't need to worry about bad,
because good is so much more powerful
than bad.
If we keep that in the forefront of what we do as scouters
and we keep these positive things in the forefront,
we won't have any time to fight with society.
Now, you and I as adults,
we've made some key connections in our brains and personalities.
I hope at least that scouts are still forming.
I think scouting is an ideal place
to form those connections
and to develop the character
to put everything that they learn in scouts
to use towards positive ends.
To me, that's the way scouting works.
It's this wonderful positive influence that you can champion
that will overcome any bad influence.
It may take time because, remember,
it's in cooperation with the developmental process
and as we develop and grow, we try out different things.
We try different attitudes and personalities,
and some of them are very positive
and some of them not so much.
But instead of getting exercised and excited
and fighting with those things that we see in scouts-
and my list was stubbornness, laziness, indifference,
shortsightedness and foolishness-
I think that pretty much covers it right-
If we stop fighting with those things
and we turn on the light,
those things start to disappear.
They're always going to be with us in one way or another.
We're going to see them in scouts and in ourselves.
So let's put our energy into what is really going to make a difference.
by focusing on every positive thing that we see in our scouts
and making sure that we call their attention to it,
and by constantly focusing on all the good,
all the wonderful potential in our scouts and in ourselves,
I think we're going to be happier that way, don't you?
I think our scouts will be happier that way
And we're going to actually do some good
and make the world a better place.
E-mail- that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your e-mails.
I did answer a specific e-mail about this particular question,
but I get e-mails periodically
and I get a lot of e-mails.
I get a lot of e-mails.
I get a lot of e-mails-
E-mails periodically asking me to recommend
a junior leader or youth leader training curriculum
that a troop can present,
And my typical reply is as follows:
I've looked at dozens of different leadership training
schemes and syllabuses and curriculums and things like that.
I've even tried a few of them.
I've even tried writing a couple, but I don't use them,
And here's why
I think that scouts are interested in doing stuff.
They're not big picture people.
They want to do things,
not sit around and be told how things work
or the theory behind why we do them.
I can think of two examples
that help explain what I'm talking about.
What happens if you're the coach of a team-
Let's call it a baseball team-
and a new player shows up?
Do we sit them down to a lecture on the theory of the game
and its history and its mechanics.
No,
After a quick introduction
we put them in the field and we throw them the ball.
We get them up and moving and active
and doing as a new player
and they're going to make a lot of mistakes
and they're not going to necessarily know what's going on.
but they will catch on
because they're actively involved in the game
And we have to remember that player came to play.
They came to play.
They don't want to sit on the bench and watch other people play.
Now they're going to practice a lot.
They're going to play a few minutes in a game here and there
and eventually they're going to begin to develop some skills.
But we're going to get them in the game.
Imagine if you try to teach someone to tie a square knot
using diagrams and presentations about the theory
and the history and the practice of knotting
and maybe a whole chapter about how rope is made.
They're going to grow kind of frustrated pretty quickly.
I would imagine I certainly would.
In comparison, if you take and you put the rope in their hands,
they're going to learn a whole lot faster
and it's a lot less frustrating for them
and maybe they'll become fascinated
with the idea of knots and ropes and things
and then want to know:
well, how did this rope get made
and what's the theory behind all this?
If a scout comes up to you and says:
I want to learn how to tie a square knot,
you put a piece of rope, you put it in their hands,
you break, tying the square knot
into its constituent elements- right,
Left over right, right over left-
and voila, there's a square knot.
They're going to practice,
They're going to try it out,
They're going to make a few mistakes.
They're going to tie a granny knot.
You're going to point out what the difference is,
but pretty soon they'll have attained the skill.
Now, I don't think training youth leaders
is any different than coaching a new player
or teaching somebody how to tie a square knot.
So you have a newly elected senior patrol leader,
newly elected patrol leader,
or the senior patrol leader is just appointed guys
into new positions of responsibility.
So where do we get started?
Well, my suggestion is
is that you train them in small steps,
just before they need the information
they're about to act on.
Our patrol leaders council meets to prepare
before every meeting,
And I may be able to take a minute or two
to ask questions about what they're going to do
and on occasion I'll spend a few minutes
telling them a few things
that might help them figure out
how to better do that.
And then we meet briefly afterwards
so that the senior patrol leader
can review what went on
and what their plans are for the next meeting,
And I get another opportunity to ask questions
and perhaps share information.
When I train youth leaders in this way,
in these relatively small steps,
I can relate fairly abstract concepts
to what they're actually doing right now,
rather than having them sit through some long event
where they're going to hear me talk for a long time.
The point is is that they're actually in the game.
They have their hands on the proverbial
rope right.
They're doing things and learning
as they go along.
Youth leaders need to know
what to do in the next few minutes
And what we do as scouters is give them
what they need and then
kind of stitch it together for them in review
Pretty soon. they're going to be self-starting.
They're going to pick up the ideas and put them to work.
Back to my baseball analogy.
Here's a glove. You put it on this hand,
Step over there 10 feet.
I'm going to throw the ball to you catch it.
Okay, you're going to need to use both hands.
You can't just catch it in the gloved hand
all by itself. You catch it and you trap it.
You got that. Now let's try that out for a little while.
Back up a little bit more.
Do you see what I mean? Active,
I'm doing it. I'm actually working
in the field.
I'm not getting a theoretical discourse
about how this is supposed to happen.
Now, this is a little counterintuitive
to the way that we think training
youth leaders should work.
What we want to do is we want
to sit down and explain
every possible thing that we can
about leadership and about planning
and preparation
and how to make things happen.
We want to give them the benefit
of our experience and knowledge.
We figure that the best way to do this
is to do it in some kind of training
event,
Something that we especially set aside.
Then, in this kind of classroom
atmosphere,
we're going to give them all of this information.
They're going to dutifully note it
or write it down, or practice it
or whatever. Then they'll
be able to go out and be leaders.
Basically,
hey, we've trained them
and now they're leaders.
They should be able to do it.
Anybody who's tried it knows
that it doesn't work that way.
No matter what kind of a course
you put together, no matter what kind
of an event you put together,
you're still going to be in the position
that I've just described
of coaching and mentoring
and moving along.
My tendency is to
skip over the first part.
Let's not worry about having a big event
or having this long training
thing. These guys are pretty sharp.
They're very action oriented.
They're not really interested in theory
to begin with. What they want to do
is make things happen. So let's get them making
things happen. Let them make the mistake
and try the shortcuts
and do all the stuff that we know
is going to happen anyway,
whether we have a training event or not.
Let them go through that and be right
there to work with and to explain
to them what's going to happen,
Along with getting requests for
training curriculums and things like that.
a lot of times, those requests
are attached to the thought that
we really want to get the patrol
method going in our troop.
We really want to start getting the patrol
system going and we need to have a starting
point and we think that training
everybody is going to be a good idea first.
Well, yes and no,
I don't want to say that
I would absolutely
reject the idea of having a sit down
and a talk about this, but I don't think
it needs to be all day long, I don't think it needs
to be an hour. I think what you do
is you sit down with the patrol leaders council
and say, hey, we are running
on something called the patrol system
as of now. It's going to be different
than what we've done before
and it's going to take us all
a little bit of time to understand how it works,
but it's going to start now. I'm going to
make just as many mistakes as you will,
but let's go for it
And then you start moving ahead. If the patrol
system is something that's new to the Scouts
and new to the troop,
it's definitely going to be new to you
and you're going to be learning as you
go along. but there's no way
to use a training
event or something like that to
inoculate ourselves against the
learning process that needs
to happen in actual
time as Scouts are trying
things out. I got to tell you
from my standpoint: it's a whole lot more fun.
It's never very orderly
and it's not all that easy,
but it certainly is
a whole lot more fun. Now, if you're running
training events and you're getting good
results from them, don't let me stop you.
I'm just sharing what
works for me and what I've found to be
effective. If you've got a question about
scouting that you are looking for an answer
to, you can get in touch with me
and I'm going to tell you how to do that in just
a moment.
Music.
Thank you so much
for listening to this
213th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast. Here's
how you can get in touch with us.
you can read the blog at ScoutmasterCGcom
and you can
subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can get the Scoutmaster
CG app on Google Play
or at the iTunes app store,
and you can also keep in touch through the
vast panorama of social media
outlets. Join the 4,900
folks who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and tweet along with the chorus
of 960 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the Pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly with
1,300-
oh, I almost made it. Pin the
Pultritudinous pictures proffered publicly with
1,300 other prolific pinners
on Pinterest. there Got it.
Watch us, if you dare, at Scoutmaster
CG on YouTube and join
the 400 odd folks who form the exclusive
Scoutmaster CG circle
on Google Plus. If you can't
face Facebook, if Twitter makes you bitter.
if you've no interest in Pinterest, if you don't
put the? U in YouTube, if you're a minus
when it comes to Google Plus,
that's alright. Bucky, Zoom into the late
90s and send me an email.
I can be reached at
Clark at ScoutmasterCGcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at
ScoutmasterCGcom,
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster
podcast are, strangely enough,
not official publications of the Boy Scouts
of America, nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America,
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
I am sure they have much better
things to do with their time. No, it's just
me talking into a microphone, trying to lend
a hand to scout leaders. and, you know,
have a little bit of fun along the way.
and here comes a little bit of fun:
Our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping. Why? thank you, sir,
until next time.